una tormenta de nieve única en una
generación así calificó el National
Weather Service el fenómeno
meteorológico que potencialmente
afectará a más de 240 millones de la
población estadounidense las imágenes
satelitales muestran grandes masas de
aire sobre la Unión Americana alrededor
de 7.000 vuelos fueron cancelados
causando caos de Cara a la celebración
de Nochebuena
nos preocupa mucho que los vuelos se
retrasen o se cancelen afortunadamente
ese no es el caso hasta ahora pero he
estado ansiosa por traer a nuestra
familia aquí a tiempo tratando de ver a
la familia que no hemos visto en muchos
años debido al covid y las carreteras
tampoco son ajenas al problema los
conductores se enfrentan a una
visibilidad casi nula en la víspera al
presidente Joe biden advirtió de la
magnitud de La tempestad en una sesión
informativa
por favor tómense esta tormenta muy en
serio Yo no sé si sus jefes los dejarán
pero si todos tienen planes de viaje
váyanse ahora no es
más de 1,25 millones de personas se
quedaron sin electricidad igual de
afectada se vio la paquetería por correo
en este sentido la empresa FedEx afirmó
que habría retrasos en las entregas a
nivel nacional para el sábado se espera
mejoras en las condiciones
meteorológicas a medida que la masa de
aire se desplace hacia el este